[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
philippe juvin bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec un jour est le chef des
urgences à l'hôpital pompidou à paris
vous êtes également maire de la garenne
colombes et on va parler également du
rôle des maires dans cette crise
sanitaire
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par pascal jalabert du jour mais bravo
jean pascal les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
philippe juvin jean castex a donc
annoncé hier soir leur confinement de
seize départements dont tous les
départements de l'île de france mais ça
rend con filmant un peu hybride avec des
écoles ouvertes des autorisations de
sortie sans vraiment de limite de temps
est-ce que ces mesures sont suffisantes
pour vous pour être franc je ne sais pas
parce que je n'ai pas compris tout ce
qui a été présenté hier c'était pas très
clair on attend je pense
le décret doit y avoir un décret qui va
être pris ce matin publié et par
expérience je sais je suis maire
également ainsi que médecin j'ai
toujours noté que entre les annonces de
la veille par voie de presse
conférence de presse et la publication
de décrets lendemain il y avait toujours
une différence abyssale entre ce qui
était annoncé et ce qui était autorisé
réellement donc il faut lire le décret
de ce matin franchement je ne sais pas
ce qui a été décidé est-ce que c'est pas
quand même de nature à poser problème
c'est à dire que au final après la une
heure de conférence de presse de jean
castex on ne sait toujours pas ce qui va
se passer
écoutez ce que j'ai compris a quasi
certainement comme tout le monde sait
qu'on ne pouvait pas aller d'une région
à une autre ça ça semble assez clair
pour le reste
quels magasins peuvent être quelques
commerces peuvent être ouverts je n'ai
pas encore compris ce que les coiffeurs
peuvent être ouverts est ce que on avait
compris que non visiblement gabriel at
elle dit le contraire ce matin l'accord
est ce que
on va avoir comme au mois de novembre
souvenez-vous ccc supermarché dans
lesquelles certains rayons seront
interdits alors que d'autres seront
autorisés il faut je suis pas capable de
décrypter la pensée profonde du
gouvernement sur une seule conférence de
presse s de nature à faire baisser la
pression chez vos collègues des services
de réanimation
alors à partir du moment où on a du mal
à savoir précisément ce qui va se passer
j'ai du mal à vous répondre je ne sais
pas vraiment posé à ct su répondre à
cette question parce que ce qu'on a
montré scientifiquement c'est que le
confinement dès lors qu'il est
strictement appliquée à des effets qui
sont des effets qu'on a pu observer au
mois de mars il ya un an
souvenez-vous sahamies facilement 4 à 5
semaines avoir des effets significatifs
là comme on est dans quelque chose
manifestement de traits intermédiaire je
ne sais pas répondre à votre question
mais le vrai sujet c'est qu'on est face
à un aveu d'échec
c'est à dire que cette cette politique
qui consistait à agir par intuition
depuis maintenant deux mois ou trois
mois en dix ans souvenez-vous le le
second gouvernement c'est à dire on
croise les doigts on croise les doigts
et puis on attend quelque chose se passe
sorte de pensée magique ça manifestement
c'est un échec puisque on voit bien
qu'on est débordée en réanimation il
faut comprendre que depuis lundi soir
nous avons en ile-de-france passer le
cap du pic du mois de novembre
donc nous sommes déjà sous l'eau mais
est ce que le médecin que vous êtes
ce matin dit bon ce sont des mesures que
j'attendais ma compris vous voulez qu'on
vous les comprenez pas ils ne sont pas
très clair mais est ce que le médecin
que vous êtes est soulagé se dit que ça
ira mieux dans les prochaines semaines
ou est-ce que ce matin il est toujours
dans l'incertitude dans l'expectative
encore une fois je je pense qu'on est
dans des demi mesures
un peu comme depuis quelques mois donc
je ne connais pas les effets de ces
demi-mesures
j'ai une certaine inquiétude parce qu'on
voit bien qu'on est dans quelque chose
de très très dur au plan sanitaire les
ligues réa j'en ai parlé je vous
rappelle qu'on a commencé à des
programmes et des passionnant c'est à
dire qu'il ya des interventions
chirurgicales justement ça des causes de
la faire et oui on est à combien de
déprogrammation pourcentage en ile de
france
on nous a demandé de nous a prêté à
faire 40 ou 50% des programmations mais
en fait on a déjà commencé
il ya un travail qui a été publiée par
par des anglais il ya il ya maintenant
quelques mois lors de la vague du mois
de mars et qui montre la chose suivante
quand vous prenez le nombre de nouveaux
cas de cancer ou le nombre de nouveaux
cas de maladies du coeur ou de diabète
et même de dépression ça a été fait sur
ces quatre pathologies qui sont
diagnostiqués au mois de mars 2018 c'est
à ce niveau là
au mas au mois de mars 2010neuf c'est à
ce niveau là et les nombre de nouveaux
cas en mois de mars 2020 c'est la moitié
donc ça signifie qu'on a on a eu au mois
de mars et on va avoir le cas cette fois
ci dans la nature
la moitié des cas de cancer la moitié
des cas de maladies du coeur ou de
diabète qui sont dans la nature qui ne
sont pas traités qui sont pas identifiés
donc vous imaginez bien que si vous
laissez traîner une maladie cancéreuse
pendant trois quatre cinq six mois de
plus eh bien oui
d'un côté vous avez des patients qui
avait pas de métastases six mois plus
tard voulait récupérer
vous avez le même patient qui a déjà une
maladie qui a progressé et donc les
chances de survie sont altérées que cet
arrêt que ça c'est pareil pour les
maladies du coeur et donc il faut bien
comprendre que dans cette crise on a
deux types de victimes
on a les patients du coc vide évidemment
avec le risque de ne pas pouvoir les
admettre en réanimation parce qu'on a
plus de place et puis on a tous les
autres patients tous les autres patients
qui n'ont pas le coc vide mais qui sous
de la désorganisation je peux vous le
faire aussi sur les rappels les arrêts
cardiaques
vous êtes dans la rue une douleur
thoracique vous effondrer c'est là qu'il
faut faire le massage cardiaque et met
un défibrillateur est bien en région ile
de france
ou plus exactement paris petite couronne
lors du confinement du mois du printemps
ça été publiés par des équipes de devant
l'hôpital on a montré qu'il y avait 100
% d'augmentation 100 % d'augmentation de
l'arrêt cardiaque
pourquoi parce que désorganisation du
système parce que en fait on n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens médicaux pour
traiter tout le monde donc le sujet de
santé publique est absolument majeur
dont concrètement là aujourd'hui on a
malheureusement le décompte quotidien
des mordus covit vous m'ont dit tu auras
une surmortalité énorme qui ne sera pas
forcément lié au vide mais c'est le
contraire vous avez absolument raison
et peut-on peut-on faire le compte de
cette surmortalité liée à la
désorganisation du système et cetera oui
il ya un autre travail qui publie je
crois dans le jama quel journal de
l'association américaine des médecins
qui a dû être publié je crois à
l'automne et de mémoire donné le chiffre
de 38 % c'est-à-dire que les patients du
coc vide qui sont estampillés que vides
qu'on vous donne le chiffre tous les
soirs représenterait dans cette étude
certes fait pas en france pendant un
pays de même niveau sanitaire
ce n'est que 38 % de tous les morts de
l'épidémie
vous voyez qu'on est face à quelque
chose qui est absolument majeur et
et les chiffres comme ça je peux vous en
donner plein donc oui on est face à une
désorganisation du système
quelle serait la solution en france par
la connaît en fait c'est ça qui est très
irritant c'est que on fait semblant de
mai plus vous vacciner la population
plus évidemment vous gagnez des vies et
que vous gagnez du temps on le voit
d'ailleurs actuellement il ya une
rajeunissement des patients en
réanimation en france on avait on a une
espèce on a une moyenne d'âge qui aux
alentours de 61 ou 62 ans
là où il ya on était plutôt à 66 67 ans
eh bien ces cinq ans ça peut paraître
peu mais en moyenne ses considérables
sont expliqués par un certain nombre de
phénomènes dont dont la vaccination des
plus âgés à revenir sur la vaccination
mais c'est intéressant ce profil des
patients en réanimation dont vous nous
dites y'a un rajeunissement est ce qui a
aussi un autre type de profil dans la
première vague on parlait beaucoup des
comorbidités est ce que là c'est
toujours le cas où est ce que ce sont
des patients avec un profil complètement
différent de nous alors c'est toujours
le cas on a des patients dans plus jeune
vous l'avez compris je le chiffre même
c'est que en gros un quart des patients
en réanimation au moins de 50 ans donc
on est sur une population qui est plus
jeune et ce sont des patients plus
jeunes avec des comorbidités bien sûr a
évidemment il ya toujours des histoires
avec des patientes 30 ou 40 ans qui
n'ont pas de comorbidité ça existe en
médecine mais c'est marginal mais en
tout cas massivement des patients plus
jeunes que yann ont toujours avec des
comorbidités et ce fameux variant
britannique qui donne en fait une
pathologie qui durent plus longtemps et
c'est parce qu'elle dure plus longtemps
que elle est plus contagieuse parce que
vous crachez du virus plus longtemps et
parce que vous faites sur une durée plus
longue
un risque plus important de
complications mais juste concrètement
parce qu'on entend beaucoup qu'elle est
plus contagieuse elle est plus
contagieuse comment est-ce que les plus
contagieuses parce que il faut pas voir
le mètre de distance à ce qu elle est
plus contagieuse parce que y'a plus
l'histoire des 15 minutes en quoi elle
est plus contagieuse
alors d'abord ce congrès en médecine on
observe d'abord les choses au cordeau
observe qu elle est plus contagieuse
premièrement pourquoi ça c'est une
deuxième deuxième explication
on a probablement pas toutes les
explications mais une des explications
c'est que comme je reste malade plus
longtemps et bien
j'ai plus de chances de cracher du virus
avant de figurer donc de vous de vous
rendre malade vous passez dessus c'est
une des explications
les transferts ça ne fonctionne pas à
les transferts d'abord c'est
indispensable au mois d'avril j'avais
comme on dit pousser un coup de gueule
en disant qu'il fallait transférer
massivement j'avais appelé à des trains
et des ddd avion sanitaire massivement
vers la france mais vers l'europe
parce qu'à l'époque souvenez vous il y
avait des tas de pays de l'union par
lequel il y avait de la place
on ne l'avait pas fait c'est comme ça
parce qu'en france on a toujours du mal
à faire des choses c'est indispensable
parce que ça nous redonne un peu
d'oxygène
sauf que premièrement à la différence du
mois de mars dernier en ile de france je
parle venus de france par d'emploi
représentants de la jeunesse régional
l'observation c'est que il ya plus de
régions impact et qu'elles ne l'étaient
il ya un an donc on a moins de capacité
à transférer dans d'autres régions et
deuxièmement on a fait le travail la
semaine dernière à l'assistance publique
des hôpitaux de paris a été étudié la
capacité de transfert des patients d'île
de france vers la province
en fait seulement 10 11 % des patients
étaient médicalement éligibles pourquoi
éligibles pourquoi parce que transférer
un patient c'est quelque chose de
difficile sont des patients qui sont
très fragiles et donc on estime que 1
sur 10 seulement pouvaient être en état
d'être transféré
et là dessus quand vous rajoutiez une
deuxième condition c'est l'acceptabilité
des familles qui peuvent dire oui ou non
eh bien on tombe est très très bas avec
je crois un seul patient dans la famille
avait dit oui donc ça signifie que cet
illusoire de penser que la question des
transferts va résoudre la question
elle nous donnera un peu d'oxygène et
c'est très précieux et il faut le faire
le plus possible parce qu'en fait on est
à quelques lits de réanimation près
comprenez ça se voit ça se joue à rien
au mois de mars dernier je me souviens
qu'il ya même un soir où il n'y avait
plus qu'un lit de réanimation dans toute
l'île de france donc on est aujourd'hui
à combien aujourd'hui on a un petit
volant de sécurité qui doit être d'une
d'une centaine de lieux mais sans lycée
quoi si demain vous aussi si en sortant
devant le sénat ya un accident avec cinq
blessés graves qu'il faut aller au
rythme et sion ils ont pas de copie de
ces gens là et pourtant il faudra qu'ils
ailleurs une nation donc comprenez
pendant que le coc vide progresse il ya
aussi les autres pathologies qu'il faut
continuer à prendre est de m'assurer là
qu'on soit bien clair les transferts à
l'heure actuelle ça ne marche pas c'est
ce que vous dites
yona mais il en attendait pas à un
miracle
le gouvernement nous disait y en aura d
elles des centaines gyan du matin et on
est on est il ya combien de temps il ya
eu combien de transfert écoutez monsieur
attal la semaine dernière a dit on va
faire une centaine de cette semaine
écoutez ça ils sont tous à nous donner
tellement de chiffres en permanence qui
se contredisent ailleurs d'un jour à
l'autre sur les vaccinations c'est quand
même quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire mais là c'est pareil il
on a l'impression que la communication
suffit comme action politique
j'ai dit que j'allais faire des
centaines de transfert donc voilà c'est
fait non non non c'est pas comme ça la
vie
il faut vraiment différencier la
communication surtout quand elle est un
peu mensongères comme celle ci qu'elle a
tendance à à dire que tout va bien et
les faits dont ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile et vous avez un chiffre de
transfert ou pas du tout en jeu laissez
les gens n'allaient pas gelé par tout
cas ça sera pas ce qui nous a été
annoncé d'accord et juste vous nous
parler ces transferts ça marche pas
c'est pour des raisons médicales ou
c'est le fait qu'ils aient l'acceptation
des familles qu'ils soient demandées
contrairement au mois de mars qui joue
beaucoup
les deux les deux c'est à dire que la
passion à demander l'avis aux familles
d'abord il est patient intubé et ventilé
fragile avec des troubles amputé
hémodynamique qu'ils font quand vous
voulez bouger c'est compliqué quand vous
interrompez la ventilation c'est
compliqué parce que vous perdez quelques
points de pression artérielle en oxygène
donc ce sont des transferts qui sont
extrêmement subtile c'est vrai qu'on a
des patients et des médecins du samu qui
les accompagnent c'est vrai qu'on
médicalisent des trains mais ça reste ce
très très très difficile c'est pour ça
que je vous dis canada que 10 % qui sont
éligibles ce qu'on fait maintenant c'est
quand les patients arrivent en
réanimation
on prévient les familles qu'on pourrait
être obligé de transférer les familles
comprennent mais mais
je comprends un patient qui arrive à
paris
qui c'est qui est hospitalisé en
réanimation et puis qui va se réveiller
je sais pas - bordeaux c'est compliqué
pour lui c'est compliqué pour la famille
mais il faut le faire tant que c'est
possible parce que c'est une petit à
petit volant de sécurité est ce que vous
nous dites le risque de saturation et là
est ce qu'on se retrouve face à un
risque dans quelques jours dans quelques
semaines de devoir trier des patients
d'abord le tri en médecine on le fait
toute l'année et en permanence quand
vous êtes de garde en réanimation et que
vous avez un lead libre dans votre unité
et que le samu vous présente deux
patients ou trier choisissez-la plutôt
que l'autre ça donc où le fait la
question est de savoir sur quels
critères on le fait et si on va être
obligé demain de ne pas mettre en
relation des patients qui habituellement
irait en l'animation c'est ça la
question
oui c'est évidemment un risque
d'ailleurs ça nous est arrivé au mois de
mars au mois de mars très clairement
dernier 2020 il ya des patients qui ne
sont pas allés en réanimation
alors qu'en temps normal il serait allé
en réanimation
tout le monde le sait et il suffit de
regarder un certain nombre de critères
en particulier les caractéristiques par
exemple des patients on sait bien qu'il
ya des patients qui ont été aussi trier
sur l'âge donc moi ma double inquiétude
elle est à la fois de ne pas pouvoir
soigner tous les patients du coc vide
mais aussi de ne pas pouvoir soigner
tous les patients qui n'ont pas le coc
vite vous avez bien compris qu'ils
allaient blanche a bien compris mais
vous dites tout le monde le sait le
gouvernement a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
eu de tri des patients lors de la
première vague vous vous dites que oui
eh oui enfin vous savez le gouvernement
vous a dit qui avait pas de problème
avec le masque le gouvernement vous a
dit qu' on ne pouvait pas ouvrir de lits
de réanimation et le gouvernement vous a
dit qu'on allait avoir enfin mars 9
millions de vaccinations c'est monsieur
verront le 21 janvier alors que monsieur
castex monsieur attal parler de 15
millions donc je ne sais pas ce que
signifie ce que gouvernement dit on va
parler de la vaccination donc depuis
l'investiture de joe biden vingt pour
cent des américains sont vaccinés c'est
à peu près deux millions huit cent mille
par jour
qu'est ce qui se passe en france
pourquoi ça ne va pas assez vite et
comment accélérer
il ya deux choses d'abord on n'a pas
commandé à cette vaccin donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un sujet là dessus mais et vous
avez raison de me permettre de le dire
quand on compare tous les pays de
l'union européenne
tous ont reçu la même quantité de
vaccins proportionnellement à leur
population et à la même date
et bien malgré cela nous les français
nous sommes toujours depuis le début de
la vaccination dans le peloton de queue
on est dans le dernier tiers des pays de
l'union donc on a outre la question des
livraisons qui ne sont pas suffisantes
on a une question logistique très
française la question logistique c'est
que nous ne sommes pas organisés et moi
qui suis mère qui est un vague cynodrome
dans ma commune je me souviens que
monsieur verrons nous explique fin
décembre ou début janvier que les
vaccinodromes ça ne sert à rien
d'ailleurs il n'y croit pas on se
demande pourquoi toi sont dans cette
gestion de la crise on est dans je crois
je pense où je suppute ce n'est pas
comme ça qu'on gère une crise et et la
logistique ne suis pas de jeu rune fois
en tant que maire mais services
municipaux ne cesse de prendre des
rendez-vous et de les annuler depuis
deux mois on ne sait pas combien de
vaccins on va avoir la semaine prochaine
peut-être que ce soir on va avoir un
coup de fil du préfet qui va nous dire
il faut ouvrir en urgence le
vaccinodromes dimanche alors que ce
n'est pas prévu parce que vous avez 200
doses en plus il ya une anarchie totale
de l'organisation il aurait fallu faire
quoi il est encore temps de le faire
s'appuyer sur des logisticiens privé il
ya des gens dont c'est le métier ou
larvées les allemands les italiens les
anglais des américains même on nommé un
général à la tête des opérations
d'organisation des choses pourquoi parce
que les militaires s'y connaissent un
peu en logistique et vous dites il était
encore temps de le faire c'est à dire
que ce matin au gouvernement jeudi au
gouvernement
soyez un peu professionnel arrêter cette
anarchie qui fait qu' on ne sait pas où
est votre colonne vertébrale c'est le
sait
il ya une désorganisation absolument
totale on ne sait pas qui est le chef
d'ailleurs vous avez bien vu hier on a
rien compris quand il ya eu les annonces
moi je pense que l'approximation
permanente sur les annonces nombre de
vaccins qui vont être faits à telle date
varie d'un jour à l'autre ou même à
l'intérieur d'une même journée entre
deux ministres j'ai tous les films qui
se sont été donné depuis trois mois
c'est délirant à chaque fois qu'un
ministre ou la bouche qui donne un
chiffre différent du précédent
ce qui permet d'ailleurs ce qui leur
permet à chaque fois dire ah bah oui on
l'avait bien dit bah oui c'est vrai que
dans la litanie des chiffres on est
toujours inquiet bron et deuxièmement
sur l'organisation elle même
il faut à la fois s'appuyer sur des gens
dont c'est le métier
ce qui n'est pas le cas la haute
administration a beaucoup de qualités
mais c'est pas d'administration de
logistique et deuxièmement il faut faire
confiance au maire pourquoi parce que
les mères ce sont des gens qui sont
débrouillards qui a trente six mille mer
en france donc il ya trente-six mille
mairie mais on peut déjà ouvrir 36000
centres de vaccination vous dites à
n'importe quel maire de n'importe quelle
commune même la plus petite de france
ouvrait un centre de vaccination dans
votre salle municipale
il le fera avec l personnel il se
débrouillera parce que encore une fois
ce sont des gens qui savent faire
il trouvera une infirmière un médecin
actifs à la retraite peu importe
et ça leur permettra ça leur permettra
d'agir 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
c'est ça qu'il faut faire
tant qu'on n'aura pas passé ce cap qui
consiste à dire on vaccine on vaccine on
vaccine
eh bien on n'y arrivera pas 7cette
malheureusement à 500 parlant de
vaccination on sait qu'il ya une
réticence 1 chez les soignants à se
faire vacciner à moins de la moitié
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on est à 41 % de
soignants qui sont vaccinées est ce que
vous dites il faut la rendre obligatoire
et est ce que vous dites qu aujourd'hui
quand on va à l'hôpital pour un problème
de genou pour un problème de coeur on
risque d'attraper le coc vide c'est
devenu une maladie nosocomiale
alors d'abord mon jeu je veux dire ici
que je trouve absolument scandaleux ce
petit cette petite musique qui depuis
deux trois semaines circule de la part
des autorités qui consiste à dire
regardez en fait les soignants sont
responsables les méchants ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner parce que c'est un peu
facile
donc moi je dis les choses très simples
autant je crois que cet indispensable de
vacciner contre la grippe parce que
c'est un vaccin pour lequel on a du
recul depuis plusieurs décennies est
extrêmement robuste
là il faudrait le rendre obligatoire
sur le co lead sur la colline on est sur
une vaccin qui est relativement récent
donc moi je suis contre l'obligation du
vaccin contre la copie de mai mais
pardon avant de contraindre les gens il
faut m'expliquer pourquoi il n'y a
toujours pas eu
nous sommes fin mars il ya toujours pas
eu une seule campagne officielle pour
persuader les gens de se faire vacciner
il ya un clip qui circulent
gouvernementale plein là royan et
sentiments plein de sentimentalisme à la
petite semaine d'une grand-mère qui
embrasse les enfants c'est très
sympathique ça une semaine et pardon
quand on ne veut pas se faire vacciner
on veut pas se faire vacciner pour des
raisons qui consiste à dire qu'il ya des
effets secondaires dont je que je crains
que c'est bien c'est cette réponse qu'il
faut apporter
où est la campagne de vaccination
officielle qu'on aurait dû prendre
depuis le mois de décembre il y en a pas
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement a eu
la pétoche de s'afficher pro vaccin à
une époque où on disait que les français
ne voulaient pas oui c'est cette c'est
cette incapacité à voir une colonne
vertébrale et assumer les choses qui est
très préoccupant donc moi je dis au
gouvernement avant de contraindre s'il
vous plaît tu essayé de persuader et
d'expliquer les choses mais vous même
comment ça passe comment ça se passe
dans votre service on imagine que
statistiquement il ya des soignants qui
devront pas les applications qu'est ce
que vous leur dites mais je leur dis une
chose très simple je leur explique les
avantages de la vaccination versus les
désavantages de voir la maladie
c'est ça qu'il faut expliquer aux
français si vous utilisez vous dit aux
français à un français de 34 ans entend
vacciner vous sinon vous allez mourir il
va vous dire mais non à 30 ans j'ai peu
de chances de mourir et il aura raison
donc c'est pas le bon argument il ya
d'autres arguments par exemple
l'argument des copies de long quand vous
faites un co vide
vous avez une chance importante
malheureusement six mois plus tard alors
même que le covin n'est pas grave de
continuer à avoir des symptômes est
emparé de réduire votre activité bien
travail qui a été publiée dans le
journal of internal medecine
il ya une semaine qui montre la chose
suivante quand vous prenez 150 patients
qui ont mis un coup vite pas grave c'est
à dire qu'ils ne sont pas allés à
l'hôpital voulait regarder
six mois plus tard un tiers ont encore
des symptômes ou une activité qu'ils
aient baissé
y compris chez les jeunes et bien
expliquer cela et vous verrez plus on
vaccinera plus on vaccinera c'est à dire
que l'exemplarité est très important et
malheureusement le temps file films jeux
vers l'enfant n'avait encore
deux questions politiques pour terminer
on va parler au maire à l'homme
politique
des questions se posent autour de la
tenue des régionales est ce que pour
vous dans le contexte actuel les
régionales peuvent se tenir
je crois qu'on a eus le président des
états unis d'amérique que tu as un grand
pays en pleine crise qu vide
les hollandais viennent de voter en
plein confinement donc oui ça suffit
enfin la démocratie ne doit pas
s'arrêter
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un an il ya
des élections présidentielles si on
continue comme ça on repousse aussi
l'élection présidentielle non les
élections c'est pas la variable d'abord
d'ajustement d'une absence de politique
sanitaire parce que vous comprenez bien
que si on en est là aujourd'hui c'est
parce que on n'a pas ouvert de lits de
réanimation depuis un an
ce qu'il aurait fallu faire j'ai lu ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui mars 2000 20
mars 2021 ya le même nombre de lits de
réanimation oui c'est ça qui est
incroyable et il ya des gens comme moi
qui ne cesse de dire il faut ouvrir des
lits de réanimation et on nous répond
cet argument faux qui consiste à dire ah
oui mais avec plus de lits de
réanimation on aurait quand même confiné
mais bien sûr tout ça est absurde mais
aucun bilan n'a été tiré de cette crise
depuis mars 2001 voit bien que en
permanence on est dans de la com on ne
tire aucune leçon des erreurs il ya un
an
moi je comprends qu'on puisse avoir été
surpris on a tous été surpris au plan
mondial
mais un an plus tard on n'est pas prêt
sur la vaccination et on n'a pas un lit
de réanimation plus
en fait on en a mille deux cents de plus
mais il faut bien comprendre parce que
l'art n'a quelle est la part dont l'art
d'actes médiatique c'est que ces 1200
lits de réanimation en plus ce sont des
lits qu'on a pris ailleurs et qui on a
repeint en lits de réanimation mais du
coup ça diminue ça n'augmente pas la
quantité totale de l'y voyait en france
c'est ça qu'il faut juste puisque vous
avez parlé la présidentielle
etes-vous toujours candidat dans votre
famille politique s'il y avait eu une
primaire est en faveur d'une primaire
est prêt à vous présenter j'ai toujours
dit que s'il y avait une primaire de la
droite et d'ailleurs je pense qu'il en
faut une parce que s'il y en a pas c'est
la quasi certitude que nous ne serons
pas au second tour
on a bien compris ça aussi c'est un
certain nombre de gens qui ne veulent
pas de primaire pas de primaires égale
probablement deux ou trois candidats de
droite au premier tour et donc pas de
constat de droite au second tour
moi je participerai à la primaire pour
deux raisons parce que la primaire c'est
d'ailleurs d'abord évidemment un moyenne
choisir un candidat unique pour le
second tour mais c'est aussi
souvenez-vous de la primaire de il ya
cinq ans le moment où on échange des
idées ou confronte des points de vue
donc oui le pays étant tel désordre que
évidemment il faut s'occuper de la chose
publique et que avec un certain nombre
d'amis j'aurai des choses à dire et vous
viendrez nous en parler merci beaucoup
je viens d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci pascal est l' une des
dernières nouvelles d'alsace et la
france de l'italie de la france à deux
vitesses avec ses seize départements
donc en rouge et confieront n'a pas trop
compris comment en effet et puis le
reste du pays avec des départements qui
sont pas loin quand même d'atteindre les
syriens le chiffre de 16 ils risquent de
monter dans la quinzaine qui vient donc
on voit bien que la question des lits de
réanimation est fondamental moi vous
avez livré de masse y ont pu vous devez
confiné oui et puis dans un département
comme le jura où il ya très peu d'imagés
il suffit que ça monte de 5 à 10% et
vous êtes tout de suite ça curie et moi
je suis de corse
je viens de corse et que je veux assurer
que la corse est une île en plus merci
philippe giffard merci
c'est notre invité ce matin en fait
suite au cas où des territoires
[Musique]